hey guys Ryan right here Alex Luthor
Luthor
whatever has another video out this
guy's becoming more popular by the
second and I love his videos
Batman versus Iron Man 50 shades version
I hear that is a funny one they haven't
seen a funny one from Alex thanks Alex
yeah a great guy this is a message
brought to you by Ryan right
yeah
I know where this is going
wait I gotta wait till Veronica gets
home she has to watch this so I went an
hour and a half of Veronica to get back
here by the way I didn't you're gonna
watch it's Batman versus Iron Man fan me
trailer 50 shades of grey style
interesting she's never seen any of the
epic fan made trailers this is like the
first comedy one he's ever done or I
don't know it was personal I'm watching
we totally
I thought it I thought it was gonna be
like more hilarious agrestic oh come on
that was pretty funny
it's cleverly edited to make it look
like they're into each other people have
always said that iron man is like
Marvel's version of Batman in a lot of
ways because he he's not a superhero he
builds a suit he's a genius billionaire
I mix it all together just like Daddy
it's cool instead of dipping some like
cool Nashville she's a great isn't it
usually like it's usually like that at
all yeah it's usually like badass versus
each other Superman versus Hulk DC
versus well usually like fights yeah
yeah like the first time there this is a
well it's just one dude and this is one
guy named Alex Luthor like he's really
good at what he does he doesn't have a
team no wow at least one I understand
how does it give anyone else credit ugly
but anyway yeah that was well worth it I
thought I thought that was a pretty
funny video it's just cuz that movie so
cheesy you read the whole book we had a
great time because of it anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects veronica
has a music and vlog channel you should
check that shiznit out as soon as you
can right now right now then you can
follow us on Instagram Twitter and
Facebook it f
I T I did well not just now I've said it
several videos and I'm gonna come up
with another acronym right now because
the other wants us to inappropriate for
us what is you know you don't want to
know
tell me know what's gonna tell you it's
just another acronym I used what
me you guys have to tell me if he
doesn't die it's called pics pyx penis
no pubes no pornhub.com you burn calm
xvideos doc I refer people to those
sites cool
now tails I'll punish myself you have
the keys to the cage